hold on to your loved ones because we
have a star-studded cast featuring Poe
Dameron King Arthur the Chilean guy from
Game of Thrones
fat man and a guy named Garrett in the
most botched heist film since ocean's 8
Netflix is triple frontier centers
around a group of ex-military who hatch
a plan to rob one of Brazil's biggest
drug lords the only problem is that it
goes horribly horribly wrong so in this
video we're gonna take a deep dive into
the ending and figure out just what
happened the movie ends with Benny
catfish iron head and Pope all giving up
their share of the heist money to read
fly's family trust fund and amount
totaling over five million dollars
that's about 2% of the total 250 million
they had originally grabbed from Gabriel
aurea's stash each of the men feel
tremendous guilt not only for red flies
death but for the countless other lives
they destroyed along the way as catfish
says to Benny I killed those people no
you did we all did
everyone is complicit in these deaths
the initial plan was to have only one
casualty
Gabriela Raya the ruthless drug lord who
committed mass executions in his
backyard
yet when all is said and done the team
ends up killing dozens of people
including farmers and teenagers and that
guilt eats away at them triple frontier
is a parable on how greed corrupts it's
greed that causes red fly to take more
money than they can handle
greed which causes the helicopter to be
weighed down by taking on too much cash
and greed which slows down the men so
that they're eventually caught by two
teenagers looking for revenge red flies
death is a direct consequence of greed
and the other men know it it gets to the
point which the money becomes
meaningless they burn it to keep warm
and even laugh while doing it their
lives are worth more than any amount of
money and they end up tossing the rest
in a chasm where no one can get to it
the five million they get at the end is
all that they could carry on themselves
but even then they all agree money can't
buy their friend back or relieve the
guilt they have placed upon themselves
the men all go their separate ways but
right before iron had asked Pope what
he'll do now that
the mission is over pope half jokes that
he'll go see this girl he knows in
Australia of course referring to you
vana
Yvonne Oh is Pope's informant and lover
who he helped smuggled out of the
country with three million dollars
Yvonne is the only one in the film who's
not corrupted by greed and she gets away
because of it her motivations unlike the
men are driven by the love for her
brother she'll do anything even risk her
life to save him they men on the other
hand risked their lives not for the good
of the people but for their own monetary
gain if Pope really cared about taking
out Lauria so that the people would no
longer be terrorized by this drug lord
he'd have done the right thing and
completed the mission with a help with
the army Pope is an interesting
character who deep down is a good person
in the beginning when he takes down the
drug den it's obvious he's good at what
he does he's calm and collected in the
face of extreme danger saves a wounded
soldier and even lets one of the other
officers take credit for the explosion
that let them advance for Pope it's not
about awards or accolades but his one
critical flaw greed is ultimately his
own demise it's also interesting to note
that Metallica's for whom the bell
tolled plays here foreshadowing the
death that will eventually plague our
characters in this way triple frontier
is an Aristotelian tragedy with the
characters succumbing to their flaws and
thus being punished for it but there is
a glimmer of hope
at the end Ironhead hands Pope a note
with coordinates the coordinates to the
chasm where they dropped the money and
as Pope disappears into the crowd were
left with the following question will he
go back for the money or will he let it
go and just for fun I typed in those
coordinates into Google and all I got
was the ocean off the coast of Brazil so
good luck for any of you trying to find
it the ending also takes place in st.
John's Antigua you can tell by the
cruise ship in the background in the
street named Prince class as well as the
fact Pope said they would get paid
through a company in Saint John's the
capital of Antigua finally I want to
take a look at the beginning scene where
Ironhead talks to a bunch of Army
soldiers he talks about how the effects
of committing extreme acts of violence
on others create biological and
physiological changes he calls this the
price of being a warrior and that's a
price all of our characters must pay and
now they must live with the
Changez some physical like getting shot
but mostly emotional the guilt and all
for what a payday that never panned out
my guess is that Pope won't go back for
the money
no amount will ever bring his friend
back nor get rid of the crimes he and
his team committed but what do you think
leave a comment below and let me know
what you thought of triple frontier make
sure to LIKE and subscribe and follow me
on twitter at pink story YT until next
time remember daddy loves you very much